die freut sich mein name ist luca
herzlich willkommen heute seinen neuen
video her viele leute haben eine lange
auf diesen moment gewartet und
verspielen wir heute reichen kohle
irgendwie fehlt hier jemanden ich meine
wenn wir heute schon reif ukulele und
wir das heute schon spielen dann
brauchen wir halt auch einen bestimmten
mitspieler und jeder mitspieler haltung
kollege aber ich weiß ehrlich gesagt
nicht rudi ist das letzte mal zu sehen
[Musik]
da sie jetzt also das letzte mal beim
marvin war der diese ukulele blogs
gemacht hat schreibe ich jetzt einfach
mal marvin direkt an namen was gehen
weißt du zufällig wo juli die gerade
befindet eine ewigkeit bitte luca shop
frage gekommen sein musste mal
vorbeischauen da beim luca shop
ich würde sagen
dann fahren wir jetzt mal zusammen zum
lucas ab und schauen danach
[Musik]
übrigens vom wettergott in köln ist der
fall schon mal fünf euro gefreut wir
haben juve linie drückt ihr im neuen
piste erwartet darüber verfügt was ist
der dritte minister für wasser ritter
gibt auf jeden fall berufskolleg kommt
der fall ist und wir wieder nach hause
spieler für wenige minuten später da
sind doch endlich wieder am start meine
damen und herren und zwar ich und
ukulele die auch am start auch nokia
verbinden und ich immer alles klar ich
habe hier leider noch keinen wirklichen
plattform ähnlich könnte die höhe
irgendwie können wirklich nicht nur an
die decke mache die hinhängen durch wir
kriegen einfach mal aufs spiel statten
gehen auf das erste level und wir können
was für dich denn hierher danke akinator
bewege dich erste den karten a und b und
schaue dich danach mit der maut oben
derzeit mit hier gelaufen mit der maut
kann ich mich verrückt
genau hier nun links und rechts schauen
ja mit weiterhin hatte der meinen hut
machen wir weiter wie du sieht ist hier
ein kleiner hügel und darüber zu
springen drücke einfach die leertaste
gedrückt hat um höher zu springen oder
bin ich hier rüber gekommen ist erklärt
er und hast du schon mal einer
doppelfolge machten so sommer
doppelsprung jetzt tue ich will dir
keine angst machen aber dafür nicht
deine freunde euro
wenn du sie loswerden willst dann
springe einfach auf sie drauf okay da
halten kann es quasi und kohle hat sich
direkt weh getan was sagst du dazu dass
wir quasi direkt beim ersten gegner
verkauft haben
immer noch die alte die ninja blade
willkommen die kate anwendet zu springen
und die blase zu nutzen sie einfach nur
berühren ab da drauf und jetzt können
wir anwenden politik ganz schöner arsch
aus um das level abzuschließen war aber
eine halbe sekunde dem portal stehen das
heißt nicht nämlich hin wenn ihr mich
auf mein gott als den niveau
er hat mich genau getroffen wird beim
einer einweisung anscheinend
eingeschlafen
kollegen verkauft wir sind ein team wir
leben und verliert und gewinnen zusammen
sowas nochmal gehe jetzt erstmal weiter
ab hatte jedoch gut auf dich auf das
heißt wir gehen einfach mal weiter und
ach ich glaube das sollte sogar seine
spender für das verpacken darüber wird
gerade gesagt vom wegen hater wahren
albtraum achtmal weiter passt überhaupt
nicht auf das heißt wir werden hier
dafür weitergehen da den qualitäten
bedient mal laufen hier weiter lange
springen hier die wand toro hierdurch
die ecke hier weiter oben da oben
besonders mal wieder töten können dann
hilft dem typen und haben mit den
tomaten zum leben zu regenerieren euro
hat er doch alle leben weil wir gut sind
oder ukulele anhand alter ich meine man
hier trotz für den privaten verein auch
wenn ich jetzt keine leben generieren
kann
dann haben wir hier den ball wieder
getötet laufen weiter haben wieder das
hinterrad ding nach 54 anwenden
hochtakten können gmbh und ich werde
dafür dort forderten level haben den
level abschluss um das ganze ding jetzt
beenden war hier hoch umfang
wir sind im level nummer drei bei der
arbeit her durch das einsammeln erhältst
du einen 3fach sprung in eine erhöhte
geschwindigkeit verliert jedoch
sprungkraft wo wir den besten doch
gleich mal aus das heißt ich bin jetzt
relativ schnell bin kleiner und balu
beträge werden balotelli wird mittel
aufpassen weil die kandidaten springen
hier mit balu aber hier weiter durch
dann hier und wie findest du meine neue
er ganz schön pfiffig braucht im shop
kommt über die weltkarte so einfachen
wie auch alle anderen level draufklicken
jetzt wer hier den bäumen 1 und können
damit an partner in dem schocker mit dem
aufkauf löffel tor aber gott mit den
ähnlich über bari mit dem hinten durch
eine kontertechnik kaufen alter hiermit
zu sammeln hier höher werden sammeln
hier fordere hier noch die münzen
sammeln den tomatensaft trinken hier
wieder hoch hier die münzen ein sagt
okay
ok ich weiß nicht ob ich die nächsten
wie soll man das irgendwie überleben die
hier wurde die blöcke langsam die nerven
point ein hier um die ecke
dollar einsammeln hier wieder einsammeln
hier oben rum lang hier ein sammel
einsammeln einsammeln entnahme robert
und hier vorne wieder lang dabei jetzt
hier und neben einer den tomatensaft
gern ich bin wieder voll geladen
ich bin wieder und leni das halt ich
kann jetzt auch hier wieder die wände
hochgehen mit sie hier als war nur
wieder durch allerdings peter falk
leute ich bin aber eben rein wo wir
haben das erwirtschaftete befinden uns
jetzt in level nummer vier arbeiter der
ab und herren damit würde ich das video
hat allerdings auch beenden loco leni
was sagst du dazu freunde und fallen
lassen würde wenn du kannst normal
machen wollen andere und garten und ich
genug von luca content filter da könnt
ihr den abonnieren -button bei terfens
los verdammt sind
der staat verbuche eingeblendet und hier
das video nicht schicken oder